[Música]
obrigado obrigado
quando eu digo que o ensino felicidade
enquanto algumas respostas né
alguns caramba como é que eu faço pra
aprender isso logo
e aqui no beck'stage também estava
falando isso alguém chegou comigo
como é que eu faço a prender o outro
grupo se na felicidade como é que é
possível é tão subjetivo e um terceiro
grupo
quando você conta uma piada aí eu falei
calma gente não vai contar uma piada
aqui mas a gente vai conversar sobre
como desenvolver a felicidade
e aí o que é interessante era bem
criança ainda mais na década de 80 eo vi
crescer a geração saúde
todo mundo preocupado com a academia com
alimentação saudável é na época em
santarém tinha duas academias
hoje tem mais de 60 e aí foi bacana essa
onda da geração saúde
hoje a gente vive uma outra geração em
geração felicidade todo mundo quer ser
mais feliz né
e aí puxa que bacana todo mundo
procurando essa felicidade nunca se
publicaram tantos livros sobre
felicidade nunca a ciência estudou tanto
sobre felicidade e uma das maiores
descobertas é que a gente realmente pode
aprender a ser mais feliz e colocando em
prática o que a gente aprendeu sobre
felicidade da para expandir a nossa
felicidade
que coisa interessante mas a gente
continua falhando redondamente em buscar
o desenvolvimento da nossa felicidade
o mundo está ficando cada vez mais
triste
em 2015 a organização mundial de saúde
revelou que a depressão é a doença mais
incapacitante do mundo é o que afasta
mais as pessoas do trabalho e no mesmo
ano divulgou que a segunda maior causa
de morte entre os jovens de 15 a 29 anos
era o suicídio loucura é essa a gente
quer ser mais feliz está ficando mais
triste
eu tenho uma interpretação disso que dá
para a gente mudar
é esse nosso erro
está errando redondamente em ser mais
feliz e como é que a gente pode mudar
isso
eu queria contar a história aqui de um
alpinista
imaginem que eu encontrei o joseph no na
base da montanha do everest a maior
montanha do mundo e eu pergunto pro
próprio joseph joseph koto objetivo
cara eu tenho que subir a montanha chega
lá no topo poxa bacana né
quando eu chegar lá você feliz o cara
pode resolver logo isso a gente alugou
um helicóptero sobe lá em 15 minutos e
que acaba parada nem tira uma foto já
está feliz são assim eu não quero é ter
um esforço nephila quase para morrer
congelar os dedos será que vou conseguir
será que não e aí eu vou dar valor a
isso
esse é um dos grandes erros que a gente
tem na na busca do desenvolvimento da
felicidade a gente acha que quando a
gente aumenta o prazer e diminui as
dificuldades a o sacrifício a dor a
gente vai ser mais feliz mas a gente viu
aqui que o josé filho ia ficar feliz em
aumentar o prazer de chegar lá no topo
da montanha
ele precisava ter dificuldade o
sofrimento que tanto a gente procura
evitar ele ajuda a gente a desenvolver a
felicidade é meu casamento não vai bem
no trocar de esposa
mas e aí é o problema que ajuda a
felicidade né
ajuda a gente desenvolver a felicidade e
aí é eu queria contar um pouquinho da
minha história eu conversando agora há
pouco na platéia encontrei um amigo
gabriel ali que tá decidido ali é o
vestibular
eu já passei por isso vários nós já
passamos por isso
nessa época eu ficava né eu tinha uma
lógica na minha cabeça que era assim eu
preciso trabalhar duro 12 14 16 horas
por dia para ter muito sucesso fama e
dinheiro e depois eu vou ser feliz
e assim eu escolhi fazer publicidade
comecei a trabalhar logo no segundo
terceiro mês que tinha passado no
vestibular e realmente consegui com
muito esforço é conquistar coisas mais
rápidas que meus amigos mas tudo que eu
conquistava parecia que não estava bom
eu queria mais e mais e mais
eu consegui ganhar vários prémios de
propaganda foi o exterior
fiz um curso em nova york mas eu queria
mais
eu ganhava alguma coisa e parece que eu
já projetava uma outra maior ainda e me
esforçava cada vez mais abrindo mão do
presente das pessoas que eu amava para
dedicar tanto esforço e tudo para o
trabalho e eu também errei redondamente
em procurar a felicidade que fui adiando
cada vez mais e aí eu queria fazer uma
experiência com vocês
isso ajuda no vestibular se você fizer
essa experiência que a gente vai fazer
agora já vai melhorar a nota do
vestibular já melhora as chances de
passar nas provas também não vou pedir
para que cada pessoa fechou os olhos e
sentem confortavelmente na poltrona
a gente vai relembrar agora o dia mais
feliz da sua vida com quem você estava o
que estava causando essa felicidade toda
revivem cada detalhe e com toda
intensidade esse momento
ok podemos voltar quando eu faço essa
pergunta em cursos e palestras já fiz
dezenas centenas de vezes o que eu ouço
na maioria das vezes em 80% das
histórias é que esse melhor dia da vida
o momento mais feliz da nossa vida ele
está ligado a pessoas foi o nascimento
de um filho foi um encontro com a
família reencontro das pessoas que ama
quem lembrou de um momento em que as
pessoas estão ligadas ao dia mais feliz
da vida repete a proporção dos 80% e 20%
das pessoas
relembro desse momento como uma
conquista foi algo que levou muito
sacrifício não teve dificuldades
problemas mas quando você passou no
vestibular
quando você quando a pessoa conquistou
uma vaga no concurso público conquistou
um título numa medalha aquilo também
trouxe felicidade lembra
quem teve uma lembrança do dia mais
feliz relacionado a alguma conquista
o bacana e realmente conquista ajuda
muito mais a gente desenvolver a
felicidade mas é mais ou menos essa
proporção que a gente tem que ter na
vida 80% do desenvolvimento da nossa
felicidade está relacionado às pessoas e
olha que coisa interessante e
relacionado ao presente né
não é o topo da montanha é aquela
jornada que eu vou chegar até lá e há o
contato que eu tenho com as pessoas
ajuda a gente desenvolver a felicidade
daquela luta desenfreada que eu tinha
pra conquistar mais coisas ganhar mais
prêmios
eu saí da agência que eu trabalhava da
agência de propaganda e montei meu
próprio negócio
eu queria que esse negócio crescer se
virasse uma rede de franquias
eu queria crescer cada vez mais rápido
tomei todos os empréstimos em banco né e
conseguiu expandir o negócio e depois
quebrar nossa falido e até na alma de
casa carro casamento e até a autoestima
foi pro fundo do poço
acho que desse tanto que eu bati no pré
sal
quase sai o petróleo de lá né e aí lá no
fundo do poço na merda mesmo eu parei
pra mim fazer uma pergunta pela primeira
vez que realmente eu amo fazer na vida
e aí refletindo sobre isso encontrei
duas respostas eu amava lê mas eu odiava
machado de assis e nunca consegui ler
machado de assis mas eu amava lei
aprender e adorava motivar as pessoas
eu faço palestra de motivação faça
pessoas subirem na na cadeira fazer uma
gritaria né
eu adorava fazer isso e aí como é que
vou ganhar dinheiro agora com isso não
pode ler e motivar as pessoas
já sei que eu vou fazer primeiro preciso
me motivará que eu tô no fundo do poço
chamei o meu uma o meu amigo mais maluco
que exige que eu conhecia né marcelo 1 a
0 quando eu disse que ia sair da agência
elite joga vai lá mesmo era muito o
negócio então era aquele amigo que mete
a pilha da corda né
então vou começar com marcelo marcelo é
o seguinte
almoçar fora sabe que estou quebrado a
pagar o almoço né
tudo bem o seguinte já sei o que vou
fazer da vida então conta lá você
palestrante
ele riu os dois minutos geovane você não
tem cabelo branco
se não sofrer um câncer no moroso tb não
atravessou o deserto que tu vai ensinar
as pessoas cara e aí eu puxa uma célula
é mesmo eu estava meio ele tentando
recuperar ainda né
voltei para a agência de propaganda mas
aquele sonho aquela vontade de fazer
palestras começou a nascer de novo
eu comecei a fazer palestras e comecei a
ler cada vez mais mais e mais puxa eu tô
fazendo valer citou lendo aí liguei pro
marcelo marcelo fazendo duas palestras
por mês
e eu já ganhei o salário da agência eu
vou mandar você praquele lugar porque
deu certo agora
e aí comecei a estudar bastante sobre o
que motiva as pessoas e descobrir a
psicologia positiva é um ramo da
psicologia que surgiu de 89 para cá que
estuda porque as pessoas são motivadas
felizes de gravatas e aí que coisa
bacana isso de maneira científica a
gente pode comprovar o que realmente faz
a gente feliz e comecei a ensinar isso
nas palestras e os resultados foram
impressionantes o todas as palestras que
a gente fez de felicidade
criamos o primeiro curso de felicidade
no brasil eu também depois fiz o curso
de felicidade da universidade de harvard
pela internet e com essa com essas
experiências que a gente tinha de
ensinar a felicidade desde a primeira
aula a gente pede para a pessoa preenche
um questionário avaliando como é que
está a sua felicidade naquele momento e
aí eu depois de algumas horas depende do
curso em 48 horas uma palestra de uma
duas horas a pessoa responde ao final
novamente o mesmo questionário para
comparar se houve uma evolução em todas
as vezes que a gente fez isso
a felicidade média tinha evoluído em
torno de 20% coisa bacana e sempre ao
final as pessoas entravam em contato
pelo facebook
mandava e meio ligavam para relatá a
mudança na vida dessas pessoas
eu lembro de uma jornalista chamada
suelen que a gente terminou a palestra a
ela pediu o microfone
então ela veio aqui pra cima e muito
emocionada começou a chorar ela disse
giovanni
eu ia desistir da minha carreira hoje
meu sonho de infância era ser jornalista
mas é tanta pressão tanta cobrança que
eu vim entregar meu cargo hoje e depois
de ter aprendido sobre felicidade eu
renovei minha vontade e agora vou
recomeçar com toda energia meses depois
ela foi convidada para apresentar o
jornal em goiânia hoje apresenta o
jornal telejornalismo goiânia coisa
bacana uma mãe entrou em contato para
dizer puxa muito obrigado
eu há anos vem lutando contra a
depressão e tem muitas recaídas não
conseguia mais trabalhar e depois de
praticar isso eu conseguir ter um ano
sem recaídas e voltei ao meu trabalho
olha que coisa bacana né e um amigo que
eu não via da época da agência
trabalhava comigo denílson ele encontrou
pelo facebook giovani.it sabe aconteceu
comigo não eu descobri um ano atrás dos
tumores no cérebro
eu precisei operar e como sequelas dessa
cirurgia eu perdi os movimentos perdi
parte da memória e desaprende andar
então nesse meu processo de recuperação
de tentar voltar à minha vida normal eu
assistir os vídeos na internet e isso me
deu um gás extra para eu voltar eu
queria te agradecer puxa cara isso aí
não precisa ganhar dinheiro com isso né
tá ótimo caramba estou fazendo alguma
diferença na vida das pessoas
e aí eu fiquei pensando se aprender
sobre felicidade e praticar por alguns
minutos estava transformando tantas
vidas e se eu começasse a ensinar isso
de maneira regularmente é toda semana de
maneira regular
que impacto isso teria uma empresa por
exemplo
e aí a gente começou a fazer isso a
primeira empresa que nos procurou era
uma pizzaria
ela estava em dificuldade financeira a
gente começou a ensinar a felicidade não
é pro pizzaiolo pra telefonista para o
garçom em seis meses
essa pizzaria dobro o faturamento foi
crescendo e dobrou em um ano tinha
chegado a triplicar o faturamento
a gente foi uma papelaria ensinar os
vendedores o entregador tudo a fazer a
felicidade a lucratividade da papelaria
cresceu 20% no meio da crise a gente foi
ensinar uma empresa de colchões
as vendas aumentaram 40%
caramba a gente consegue desenvolvendo a
felicidade melhorar os relacionamentos à
nossa volta
aprender mais viver mais de ter mais
saúde é crescer mais profissionalmente
ainda dá lucro que coisa bacana isso
mas afinal como é que a gente aprende a
desenvolver felicidade né
podemos começar eu fiz três passos
rápidos para ajudar a gente
primeiro é viver bem
segundo como viver bem e o terceiro é
espalhar o bem
há um grande segredo da felicidade é que
não adianta só saber
a gente precisa praticar é como andar de
bicicleta
se a gente não pratica não tem como
andar de bicicleta e como é que a gente
pode praticar viver bem
primeiro é desenvolver diariamente a
gratidão
como é que eu posso desenvolver
diariamente a gratidão praticar isso
todo dia para um minutinho por dia para
agradecer três coisas do dia anterior
para hoje você tem alguém pra agradecer
escreve uma carta para essa pessoa liga
ou melhor ainda vai lá pessoalmente leia
a carta entrega pra ela eu fiz esse
experimento gravando botei na internet e
fazer o teste antes depois aumentar em
15% a felicidade
logo depois coisa bacana a gente pode e
é muito fantástico de descobrir o nosso
propósito é que eu vim fazer aqui fazer
aquela pergunta que eu fiz lá quando
estava quebrada e quando você usa esse
propósito queria um compromisso neto tem
que chegar o topo da montanha correr
atrás dele
isso faz a diferença cuidar do corpo e
da alma
comer bem e se alimentar bem praticar
exercícios faz realmente bem pra
felicidade
uma prática que no ocidente a gente
chama de mais de funece que é a
meditação ocidental praticamente
praticar por cinco minutos faz a gente
desenvolver novas conexões no cérebro no
córtex pré frontal esquerdo de concentra
felicidade
então essa prática muito boa para nos
ajudar e aguardar por algo de bom
quando você programa uma viagem ela não
começa quando você embarca no avião ela
começa naquele momento que você definir
a data e já começa a gente já começa a
sentir bem desde hoje elevam hormônio
que a serotonina em 27 por cento quando
você aguarda algo de bom então sempre
ter projetos pra frente é muito bacana
para desenvolver nossa felicidade
conviver bem
a primeira coisa que tem que fazer é
perdoar seu primeiro a pedir perdão
quando errar e perdoar as pessoas guarda
mágoa é o mesmo que tomar veneno
querendo que a outra pessoa morra
não faz sentido e a gente precisa
aprender elogiar as pessoas sair de casa
com o compromisso de fazer pelo menos
três elogios
se eu tenho esse hábito de fazer três
elogios todo dia eu desenvolvo a
produtividade na equipe e melhora a vida
à minha volta
tenho um amigo do peito um amigo é tão
importante aquele amigo confidente
quando a gente tá com um problema de má
do tipo marcelo está com um problema de
madrugada
você liga para conversar com ele faz
melhor para nossa saúde do que ter um
carro super luxo tem uma casa na praia
tem um amigo do peito faz muito bem para
a nossa felicidade e espalhar o bem
quando a gente descobre o nosso talento
nossas forças e virtudes e usa isso a
serviço das pessoas
a gente está espalhando bem e faz muito
bem para a gente isso também
e uma outra coisa que pode ajudar muito
a gente desenvolver a ver a felicidade
espalhar o bem é sair de casa com o
firme propósito de fazer três gestos de
bondade sair de casa para ajudar de
alguma forma as pessoas três gestos de
bondade por dia imagina a gente fazendo
uma conta rápida três vezes 365 dias a
gente vai ter feito mil gestos de
bondade
a cada ano imagina essa platéia toda
fazendo o mesmo gesto de bondade a cada
ano a transformação que a gente não vai
ter no mundo
então essa idéia é a gente levar o
ensino da felicidade para as escolas e
para as empresas e espalhar o bem
um grande abraço muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]